- [Lecturer] You've probably
heard the phrase that
for every force,
there's an equal and
opposite reaction force.
And this is also known as
Newton's third law of motion,
but it's also one of the most
misunderstood laws of physics.
So that's why we're going
to dig into it a little bit
in this video.
So I have two examples here
where Newton's third law
or this notion of an
action and a reaction force
is happening.
So over here, you have this plane flying
and the plane is able to move forward
by pushing air particles
through these jet engines.
So these air particles are pushed outward
at a very, very high velocity
out the back of the engines.
If you are to enlarge one
of those air particles,
let's say, this is this
purple dot right over here.
There is a force that
is being exerted on it
by the jet engine.
And that force is going in that direction.
So what is the equal and
opposite reaction force?
Well, the equal and
opposite reaction force
is not also are occurring
on that molecule.
It's what the molecule
is doing to the plane.
The equal and opposite reaction force
is that the molecule
is going to be pushing
on the jet engine with an
equal but an opposite force.
So it's going to go in
the opposite direction.
And that's how the jet is
able to accelerate forward
by pushing on these particles
and accelerating them
backward by exerting a force on them.
The equal and opposite force is the force
that the particles,
those molecules of air
are exerting on the jet
and moving it forward.
The same thing here is
going on with this rocket.
You have some rocket fuel in there.
It gets ignited.
It explodes.
And as it explodes,
there's a force that exerts
on those little molecules
and that force is going in this direction.
But as it does that,
there's an equal and opposite force
that the molecules are
exerting on the rocket.
The rocket is having a force acted on it,
once again, equal and opposite.
So it's important to realize
that the reaction force
is not on the same object.
It's on the other object.
If one object is putting
an action force on another,
then the second object is
putting a reaction force
on the first.
The forces do not cancel out.
It's also important to realize that
both forces are generated in pairs
and happen at the exact same time.
There's no delay.
We can look at other examples of this.
This is a scenario that I would
never want to be caught in
being drifting through space.
Now this astronaut here has
some type of a rocket pack
that might help him move around.
But let's say that your
rocket pack ran out of fuel
and you're just drifting through space.
How can you get back to your spaceship?
Well, if you have a
wrench or something on you
that you can throw,
if you can take that wrench,
and if you can push that
wrench in that direction,
and let's say your spaceship
is over here to the left.
Well, the equal and
opposite force is the force
that the wrench is going to
exert on you, the astronaut,
and then it will push
you in that direction
and accelerate you in that direction.
So that's a useful thing,
if you're ever get caught
drifting through space.
But you could do an experiment right now.
Press on the table in front of you.
When you press on that table,
you're clearly putting
a force onto that table.
If your table is soft, you
will see it get compressed.
But notice your finger itself
is also getting compressed.
And the whole reason why
you can even feel that
is because your finger
is getting compressed.
And that is the equal and opposite force
that the table is putting on your finger.
And this can happen at very,
very large distances as well.
The whole reason why the Moon
is in orbit around the Earth
is because there's a gravitational force
of Earth's mass acting on the Moon.
But there's an equal and
opposite force of the Moon
acting on Earth.
And it's actually not
that the Moon is rotating
around the Earth.
It's actually, they're
both rotating around
the center of mass of their combination,
that just happens to be
so much closer to Earth.
It's actually within Earth's volume
that it looks like the Moon
is rotating around the Earth.
And this isn't just celestial bodies.
I weigh 165 pounds.
That is the force that Earth
is acting on me due to gravity,
but it turns out that there's
an equal and opposite force
of 165 pounds that I am
pulling on Earth with.
So I will leave you there.
Look around the world.
This is happening everywhere.
For every force,
there's an equal and
opposite reaction force.
But they don't cancel out
because they're acting
on different bodies.